once in a while an athlete comes along
who is so perfect to what they do they
redefine the
limits of human ability people like
usain bolt or muhammad ali took physical
prowess and
made it into an art form yet their names
still pale beside that of one man
jesse owens was likely the greatest
athlete of the 20th century before it
finished high school he was faster than
most olympians
while still in college he set three
world records and
matched a force all within one
unbelievable 45-minute period by the end
of the 1936 berlin olympics he was the
world's greatest sprinter able to
demolish the
aryan superman sent to challenge him
with absolute ease
but while the olympics made him famous
there's much more to the story of jesse
owens than
that one shining moment born into dire
poverty
in an era of racial violence owens
overcame the challenges of life in a
segregated society to rise to the top
but within months of his historic
victory he'd been banned from racing
and reduced to sideshows rejected by the
country had just won
four gold medals for a story of pain
triumph and humiliation
this is the life of jesse owens the
athlete who humiliated hitler
[Music]
when james cleveland owens was born on
september 12 1913
it was into poverty so biting it's a
wonder the boy wasn't simply swallowed
whole the tenth child of an alabama
sharecropper owens was just two
generations removed from the horrors of
slavery
and life for the poor and black was
still a nightmare the entire family was
forced to live in one tiny shack outside
oakville while
his dad henry's work barely brought in
enough to cover food and necessities
and that's when they could afford food
at all in later life owens would save
his childhood
i can remember many days of hunger days
where there was not enough clothing to
cover our bodies
days of embarrassment yet while they
were dirt
poor they weren't miserable in the place
they lived in the era they lived
everyone was dirt poor
young jc as the family called owens
wouldn't find out for years that there
was
any other way to be in a way this
ignorance was a comfort blanket he could
be happy with his one-room school with
helping his dad haul cotton in the
fields because he simply didn't know any
different
for owens as parents though their
situation was all too clear
and all too desperate there's a story
from jaycee's fifth birthday in 1918.
that day the boy noticed a lump on his
chest he tried to ignore it but it grew
bigger until it was pressing on his
lungs and
making it difficult to breathe unable to
afford medical care his mother
sterilized a knife in a flame
then while henry owens sat weeping in
the corner she made young jc bite down
on a strip of leather
and cut the lump out of him the removal
of the tumor left a golf ball-sized hole
in the boy's chest that wouldn't stop
bleeding
according to owens it was only when he
went out with his father into the dark
hot alabama night and
prayed with him that the wound finally
healed nor was this the only illness jc
suffered
throughout his childhood he had repeated
brushes with bronchitis and pneumonia
yet the family's financial situation was
so precarious that he still had to work
in the fields as much as possible but
don't go thinking that this was all
a childhood of work and no play though
owens and his many siblings helped henry
pick cotton they also had a ton of free
time
free time owens spent running barefoot
through the dusty fields
you won't be surprised to hear that
those moments were the happiest in the
boy's life
but if owens was young enough and
sheltered enough to ignore his parents
hard scrabble existence there was no way
he could ignore the way that society was
changing
the outbreak of world war one had caused
a labor shortage in the north's
factories so
used to relying on european immigrants
not long after the resurgence of the ku
klux klan led to renewed racial violence
across the south with
lynchings and race riots exploding in
cities taken together these two factors
caused one of the biggest mass movements
in american history
the great migration starting in 1916
millions of rural black southern
families packed up their bags
and headed north to take factory jobs in
the cities among them
were the owens in early 1922 when jc was
just eight
his family left behind their home in
alabama and headed to cleveland ohio on
his first day in his new school the
teacher asked for his name
owens told her he was called jc but his
southern accent was so sick that the
teacher misheard and wrote jesse from
that moment on
the boy would be jc no more he would be
jesse owens until the day he died
[Music]
despite the promise of the great
migration the owens didn't find life
easier in the north
henry and the older boys got low-paying
jobs in factories while
jesse worked a string of odd jobs after
school loading freight cars one week
working in a shoe repair store the next
at this point his greatest ambition was
to open his own shoe store there was
nothing to suggest that
he might go down the route of
professional athletics it would take an
outsider to put him on the path to
greatness
charles riley was the phys ed teacher at
fairmont junior high school
one day he saw the young lanky teen
running in the playground the boy was
such a natural that riley told him he
should train when the boy said that he
was too busy with work after school
riley offered to let him train in the
mornings and so it was that jesse owens
finally began to take running seriously
at this stage owens wasn't yet the
miraculously fast runner that he'd
become
in fact he wasn't even the fastest riley
had coached plenty of other boys in
cleveland had
a natural talent for spleed where owens
differed was his ability to take
instruction
riley didn't need to fight against
natural arrogance or laziness
whatever he said owens nodded took it on
board
and used it to improve his method by the
time the teenager moved up to east
cleveland technical high he was
progressing so fast that riley followed
him as a volunteer coach
but reilly wasn't the only important
person that owens met
in 1928 that same year owen set eyes on
minnie ruth solomon for the first time
the woman he'd one day marry but first
the couple had to survive the misery
of the early 1930s as the great
depression bit henry owens was thrown
out of work leaving jesse scrambling to
support his family
at the same time his running didn't seem
to be going anywhere he entered the
midwestern preliminary trials in 1932
but
lost all of his races but this would
soon turn out to be just a minor hiccup
in spring 1933 owens at last began to
hit his stride pulling out the
jaw-dropping winds
that would be a hallmark of his career
at the ohio into scholastic finals he
won 75 of the 79 events he entered
not long after at the national
championship in chicago he tied the
world record for the 100-yard dash while
still a high schooler
it was such a feat that the world began
to take notice of this lanky slightly
dorky looking boy from the south
owens was inundated with university
offers but he felt he couldn't accept a
place just
anywhere he needed to be both close to
his family and
able to work and earn some money for his
parents the only place that fit the bill
was ohio state
although the college didn't offer him a
scholarship they did allow him to train
with larry snyder one of the few elite
coaches to work with black kids
classes also had a schedule that allowed
owens to work as a night
elevator operator at the ohio house of
representatives earning 100
a month still the setup wasn't perfect
ohio state was racially divided
owens was expected to sleep off campus
and when the athletics team went out to
competitions he had to stay in separate
hotels and eat in separate restaurants
but if this bollard owens it didn't let
it affect his running by right the 1935
big ten athletics meet in michigan
should have been a bust
owens had injured his back and snyder
begged him to take the day off but owen
said that he wanted to try
the hundred yards and see how things
went turns out
they were going to go unbelievably well
in a single 45-minute period owens went
from barely being able to walk due to
his injury to breaking
three world records and tying a fourth
as owens dominated the 100 yards the 220
yards the 220 yards hurdles and
set a long jump record that wouldn't be
broken for 25 years
it was clear to everyone that this kid
was certainly something special
but it would only be two years later in
a city some four thousand miles away
that they realized just how unique jesse
owens
really was
[Music]
at the same time that jesse owens was
transitioning from talented teenager to
world record breaker the nation of
germany was undergoing its own
transformation
back in 1931 when owens was still in
high school the international olympic
committee had awarded the 1936 games to
biomart germany unfortunately two years
later weimar germany had been replaced
with nazi dictatorship and
now everyone was feeling super awkward
about the whole berlin olympics thing
in april 1933 the nazi sport office
officially banned non-aryans from
athletics things looked so bad that the
u.s amateur athletic union or aau
considered pulling out
that they didn't is thanks to one man
avery brundage was head of the u.s
olympic committee and a guy absolutely
determined to let his team compete
fascism be damned in 1934 he went to
germany and reported back that jewish
athletes were being treated fairly not
realizing things had been staged for his
benefit thanks to brundage's report the
aau voted narrowly to attend the games
for jesse owens it was the best present
that he could get owens had been vocal
about wanting the olympics to go ahead
correctly sensing that
this was his chance to make history
although naacp had issued a stern rebuke
to black athletes who considered
participating
owens shrugged it off he already lived
in a society that discriminated against
people like him who cared if germany was
yet another country that didn't like
black folk adolf hitler's olympics
opened on august the first with a
spectacular ceremony
memorably captured on film by real life
stormfront equivalent
lenny reivenstahl but while the games
were designed as a showcase for the
reich hitler was sure to show
only the good parts for the whole
fortnight racial laws were quietly
relaxed when jesse owens arrived with
the american team he was amazed to
discover he could ride at the front of
buses
and eat at any restaurant he chose great
as this was though
owens was here for only one thing it was
to win
and when he did the games started on
august the 2nd
the very next day owens won his first
gold hitting the tape at the end of the
100 meters just a tenth of a second
ahead of his teammate
it was the first of four goals for the
athlete and one that gave rise to a
persistent myth
that hitler snubbed owens after his win
yes that is absolutely a myth as much as
it makes sense that hitler wouldn't want
to congratulate a non-aryan athlete
owens race wasn't why the dictator
didn't shake his hand
at least not directly the day before
when owens hadn't been competing hitler
had caused outrage by only
congratulating german
and finnish gold medalists the ioc told
him that he had to either congratulate
everyone or no one being a petulant
hitler chose the latter not realizing
this the american media saw him refuse
to meet owens and
reported it as a snub but even this
might not be the whole story
one sports writer present claimed he saw
owens led below the honor box where he
smiled and bowed and
hitler gave him a friendly little nazi
salute the theory is that hitler was
swept by
in the audience's adoration german
spectators were literally shouting
oivens oivens and hitler felt compelled
to acknowledge him
still while the story of the snub isn't
true that doesn't mean owens hadn't just
humiliated the third reich
here was a black man not just beating
hitler's aryan superman
but beating them with such ease that it
was like watching the flash run
rings around elmer third and owens was
only just getting started
[Music]
for those two weeks in berlin jesse
owens existed on a plateau
above mere mortals he picked up another
gold in the 200 meters and yet another
during the long jump that last one
incidentally was where he befriended
german athlete carl ludwig long who
gave him some brotherly advice between
jumps that led to owen's beating long at
his own game between events owens was
mobbed by fans all of whom
wanted to feel some of his magic rub off
on them that august owens was bigger
than even lebron james is today
in ohio a statewide jesse owens day was
decreed it was a beautiful moment
and it's the one that we all still
remember the moments when the sports
watching world came together to
celebrate the prowess of
one impoverished black athlete from the
south
well hold on to that good feeling while
you can because the real story
is soon gonna take a darker turn the
final event owens took part in
was the 400 meter relay it wasn't an
event he'd been scheduled to run in but
avery brundage remember him the u.s
olympic committee head who reported
jewish athletes were being treated well
in germany
decided not to offend hitler by letting
a jewish runner compete and
drafted in owens as a replacement it was
a sordid decision but it did allow owens
to net one final gold medal
bringing his total hall to four in four
separate events a
feat no one would equal for 48 more
years as owen collected his
record-setting fourth gold
he remarked at the podium there's a
grand feeling standing up there
i never felt like that before sadly this
marked the
final glorious high of owens's athletic
career
the dream started to tarnish the very
next day with owens a global phenomenon
avery brundage realized the aau could
make a
killing off him so he signed the team up
to compete in events across
europe without paying them a single
penny before the games had even ended
owens was dispatched to cologne to
compete in a race
the very next day brundage sent him a
loan to prague without a dime to his
name by the time he arrived owens was so
hungry he had to ask a fellow passenger
to buy him food
from there it was another race in
germany and then a flight to england
that arrived so late owens and the team
were forced
to sleep in an empty aircraft hangar it
was an exhausting schedule by the time
of his london races owens was clearly
flagging not even
hitting times he'd made as a teenager
under charles riley it lost 11 pounds
since arriving in europe and
there was more to come without
consulting him brundage signed owens up
to a packed schedule of races
across scandinavia none of these would
generate any money for owens
all the while telegrams were arriving
from the u.s offering him thousands of
dollars to appear on popular radio shows
perhaps it's no wonder jesse owens
decided that he had enough on august 15
1936 owens ran a third leg in a relay
race in london it was a
nothing burger of a race a minor event
that seemed completely unremarkable at
the time
little could anyone watching have known
but this would be jesse owens's last
ever race
that same day owens told brundage that
he was through that he was exhausted
sick of running and was
catching that boat back to america so
avery brundage did what
any sane reasonable human being would do
he destroyed jesse owens's life like an
overgrown man baby throwing the most
pathetic tantrum in recorded history
brundage demanded the aau permanently
suspend owens from racing it was a
suspension brundage would
zealously enforce for the next 40 years
ensuring the world's greatest sprinter
could never compete again for jesse
owens it was the end of the berlin dream
and it was the beginning of a long
nightmare
we're now at the point where the story
of jesse owens usually ends with
him enjoying a ticket parade in new york
an american hero it's the warm
cozy version of jesse owens's life the
one that makes us feel good about
ourselves
is also sanitized to the point of
irresponsibility
the narrative that owens went to berlin
and humiliated hitler for team usa may
be true but it completely leaves out how
america
in turn humiliated owens this was an era
when even sporting heroes couldn't
escape racial discrimination
when the president could invite every
white athlete from the olympic team to
the white house
but snub the greatest athlete of them
all because of his skin color
zoens himself told a crowd hitler didn't
stump me it was roosevelts who stumped
me the president
didn't even send me a telegram but maybe
it's no wonder we gloss over this part
no one likes a sad story no one likes to
hear how
owens was forced to ride the freight
elevator up to his own celebration party
because the main elevator was reserved
for whites
so if you like your history soft and
sanitized
just switch off now because the real
story of jesse owens doesn't end with
his victory
but with america slowly grinding down
its own hero the most immediate and
pressing problem was brundage's
vindictive racing ban despite all the
offers of well-paying jobs back home
owens had found most of them amounted to
nothing but he could no longer make
money by competing in the usa either
in desperation owens tried looking
further afield landing a contract to run
against the cuban sprinter conrado
rodriguez in havana
just after christmas but then brundage
let rodriguez know that he could run
against owens in havana
sure but if he did so he would never be
able to run in the usa again
when rodriguez inevitably pulled out the
organizers were forced to come up with
a desperate last-minute replacement and
that's how on a wet christmas in 1936
just four months after winning a record
haul of gold medals
jesse owens found himself running not a
serious race in cuba against a serious
opponent
but against a racehorse yes in front of
3000 people
during halftime at a soccer match owens
took on the horse at 100-yard dash
reducing his incredible talent
to a mere sideshow attraction at the
time he spoke about how grateful he was
for the opportunity to run again
but much later he would confess that it
was demeaning those races made me sick
he said i felt like a freak sadly this
would now be his life
after racing the horse in cuba owens
realized that these sorts of humiliating
spectacles
were the only way he could legally run
so he began racing dogs motorbikes
trains and
even joe lewis the world heavyweight
champion knowing how one-sided that race
would be
owens gamely pretended to trip giving
the boxer a fighting chance
when owens tried to work a regular job
it invariably failed in 1938 he
co-founded a dry cleaning company
boasting that his status as the world's
fastest man
would mean clients would get their
shirts back in double quick time
but the business went under in barely a
year in may 1939
jesse owens filed for bankruptcy just
think for a second
about how strange that is like if usain
bolt had gone from the 2008 olympics to
waiting tables at denny's or something
like that yet this was the world of the
1930s
a world in which a black man of
unbelievable talent could be screwed
over
by one petty white jerk holding a grudge
thankfully owens would live long enough
to see that change
in the end it took gerald ford for a
president to officially acknowledge
jesse owens
that's 40 years 40 years after white
athletes you've never heard of got to
party with fdr
while black olympians were frozen out
during those four decades owens lived a
roller coaster life oscillating wildly
between periods of unemployment and
relative wealth
among his lowest moments stunt races
aside were getting fired from a sales
position within six weeks working
briefly as a nightclub entertainer and
being prosecuted for tax evasion
on the other end of the scale though
omens could often use a celebrity to
land well-paying jobs like his stinted
pr or as a motivational speaker
while these jobs invariably fell through
they were enough to keep his family
in a comfortable middle-class existence
as someone who'd known grinding poverty
in his childhood owens wasn't shy about
wanting to make money he famously once
said
of the raised fist black power salute
that the only time the blackfist has any
significance
is when there's money inside it was a
quote that generated a ton of
controversy but perhaps it also shows us
some essential truth about jesse owens
he'd come from nothing to make a success
of himself only to watch as
his running career was snatched away
maybe it's no wonder he concluded that
wealth was the only way to make america
respect a black man
yet even in these wilderness years owens
never lost his spark of greatness
in 1950 aged 36 he ran a 100-yard
charity dash in milwaukee
his time was 9.7 seconds almost as fast
as his legendary performance back in
1935.
even now he still had it the low period
of jesse owens's life finally came to an
end in 1955. that year president
eisenhower named owens an ambassador of
sports
the idea was that it traveled the world
operating running clinics as a way to
promote american soft power
during the cold war but for owens it
really meant two things
a chance to travel and a chance to
finally earn a stable income
as the decades passed and the berlin
olympics got further away
the american establishment slowly began
to embrace the athlete
that it had once shunned owens was
appointed to several sports associations
even working for the u.s olympic
committee
famously this led to him attempting to
mediate between the usoc and
tommy smith and john carlos the two
athletes who raised the black power
salute at the 1968 olympics a natural
conservative owens intervention was seen
as
out of touch by the civil rights
generation who dismissed him as
an uncle tom yet owens wasn't aware of
the racial tensions rolling america at
the time
four years later he had declared he
changed his mind on black militancy
finally in 1976 owens got the white
house recognition it's so long been
denied
that year gerald ford awarded him the
presidential medal of freedom
just three years later jimmy carter
would further bestow the living legends
award on him
at last owens was taking his rightful
place as america's sporting hero
it happened just in time jesse owens
died on march 31 1980 at the age of 66
a lifelong smoker it was lung cancer
that finally got him
with his passing owens left behind a
strange shining legacy
one that's perhaps unique to this day
his performance at the 1936 olympics is
legendary he remains
a household name right up there with
jackie robinson or muhammad ali yet
while robinson and ali
and others like them are known for long
spectacular careers
owen's fame rests on a single 15-month
stretch
one year plus some change from the big
ten meet in 1935 where he broke
three world records to the olympics in
and yet this was enough to ensure that
we'd still be talking about him 85 years
later
the story of jesse owens is many things
a tale of triumph over adversity of
discrimination in 20th century america
and of the moment adolf hitler saw his
dumb racial theories
face plant in the mud but it's also a
what if
what if owens had been able to keep
competing to
keep reaching for glory after the
olympics well
or sadly never know but it almost
doesn't matter
in his two short career jesse owens
managed to give us an icon
a sporting hero whose life still remains
relevant
to this very day so i really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe
thank you for watching